Speaker 1: Okay, real quick, I don't have a
ton of time for this particular story, but I
think it's an important one to mention. We have
a situation right now where the Republican Party
is blaming Biden for everything but
actively blocking solutions. And this
might not really be a shock to you. It's like,
hey, David. Yeah, welcome to American politics,
particularly Republican politics. They're
blaming Joe Biden for the high gas prices. But
just about every Republican or every Republican
voted against the crackdown on gas price gouging.
They're blaming Joe Biden for the baby formula
shortage, but they voted against a deal that a
bill that would actually deal with the shortage.
And now they're saying put us in power in November
and it's terrifying, but they have a pretty good
chance at taking over. So a couple of different
articles here to look at. First of all, full list
of 192 House Republicans who voted against the FDA
baby formula bill. Okay. The House last week
passed a $28 million emergency spending bill
to address the baby formula shortage. It passed
231 to 192, mostly along party lines. All House
Democrats supported it, only 12 Republicans
did, and 192 Republicans voted against it.
Hey, here's a problem. They claim to want to solve
it. If you look at, for example, Elise Stefanik's,
she's a Republican congresswoman and you look
at her Twitter. Joe Biden owns this baby formula
crisis. She's posting pictures of babies. She's
doing all these that were actually that might just
be a picture of her on birth announcement. Yeah,
that is that has nothing to do with baby formula.
But if you if you not directly anyway if you
scroll down her Twitter you see gas now at
historic high energies. Biden's energy crisis.
Joe Biden never should have let the baby formula
crisis reach this point, and then they vote
against the bill that would deal with it. You
look at the gas prices, there was a bill passed
by the House to deal with gasoline price gouging.
It passed at 217 to 207 with no Republicans voting
for it and also four Democrats voting against it.
They complained that Democrats do nothing. They
blame Biden for problems. Democrats put together
bills to actually deal with some of these issues.
And they vote against them and some. Times,
they'll say, Well, the bill wasn't perfect, and of
course, no bill is. But this is not really just a
problem of Republicans. What Republicans are doing
is unconscionable. But we have to also say, where
is the Democratic communications arm? It's like
it's nonexistent. There's no coherent messaging.
There's no coherent marketing and PR strategy.
Republicans are actively, actively sabotaging
baby formula, gas prices. All of these problems
that there's at least an idea of how to
not fix permanently but improve upon.
And Republicans are getting in the way
of all of it. And unfortunately, Democrats are not
coherently united with a cohesive strategy to say,
look at what they're doing. Look at what
they're doing. One last thing. There's a
lot of criticism of how, despite controlling the
Senate, Democrats can't get a lot of stuff passed.
I think it's important to understand that
when most things need 60 votes in the Senate,
if you have 50, you don't really control it. Sure,
you control the agenda. And if there is a tie
on something that you need 51 votes for,
Kamala Harris can can make that 51st vote.
But when you need 60 votes, it's a bit of
a misnomer. No more to say. You control the
Senate. You can control the agenda. And I think
that that's an important thing to keep in mind.